like my hearty here with a gamespot news
update so if you weren't ready for the
Star Wars Battlefront beta at the end
yet turns out you're in luck in order to
help dice and EA prepare for a smooth
launched the beta has been extended to
octobre 13 one day later than originally
planned one extra day may not sound like
a lot but if you've been enjoying the
beta it does sound like a good way to
kick off the week according to developer
dice as we get into late stages of the
beta the developer will begin conducting
more technical tests on its
infrastructure the tests start today
October twelfth and will run through
tomorrow according to the same press
release dice is looking for extreme
scenarios which means some players may
experience occasional issues such as
being kicked from the game or losing
connectivity the Battlefront beta
launched october eight and was
originally scheduled to end today it's
being held across pc xbox one and ps4
while the full game is scheduled to
release november 17 so i hear there's a
rumour circling the internet that the
rebels actually want a game of Walker
assault I'll believe that when I see it
for more news stay tuned to gamespot com